this is a production of Cornell
University
um so I my background is in hydrology so
this talk is mostly hydrology with some
kind of agronomy agriculture thrown in
just so you kind of know what
perspective I'm coming from in terms of
the project I've been working on this
with a grad student Sheri Martin who's
here and then also dr. Theresa selfi
who's at SUNY ESF she's a rural
sociologist all three of us are actually
have subleased one Cornell degree so I
guess it's a good pedigree so in terms
of just some background on the project
so this is funded by USDA so two years
ago almost they had a new program come
out the water for agriculture challenge
instead of the context of it was
2013-2014 and clearly a lot of the
motivation was because the drought out
west so when I was sort of contemplating
is there anything to propose its can you
really come up with anything as
compelling as what's going on out west
so one question that kind of occurred to
me and I think have occurred to other
people is what is the potential if it's
if it's harder to sustain agriculture
out west to shift agriculture back use
right and that seems like a reasonable
question to ask with the idea of the
intended impact of the water for
agriculture challenge is to ensure
quantity and availability of water
supplies so if you want more water out
west why don't you take your agriculture
somewhere where you actually have water
but then a few other questions arise
with that so one thing so I was just
looking at some papers just this is more
of a climatologist apply in the West so
this is just someone mapping out
reservoir storage in the Colorado River
Basin so basically storage and Lake
Powell Lake Mead so that's the black
line so they're tracking that from two
thousand five to twenty or if that's the
green line so from two thousand five to
twenty fourteen but at the same time
what they also did is they also looked
at groundwater and the way that
groundwater is they use what's called
grace the grace program from NASA which
is the satellite program and it looks at
small changes in the gravimetric field
of the earth and what they can do is
they can detect at a regional scale
changes in groundwater storage so
interesting thing with this graph is
they basically saw 2010-2011 people are
concerned that Lake Mead might go dry I
basically
he covers but what they continue to see
is they see groundwater levels go down
and stay down so this kind of suggests a
few sort of interesting things related
to my project and also western water
which is one is that the drought has
probably to some degree impacted Western
water production but to the other degree
it's its Western production of
agriculture is to some degree probably
been mitigated by reliance on
groundwater so if we sort of look at 10
20 years out when that groundwater isn't
there will there be a more obvious need
for shifting things somewhere else the
third thing that it does in terms of
some perspective for thinking about New
York is it is it highlights the fact
that even out West where there's these
irrigation districts and well known they
see is a definite need for managing
water there's been gaps in terms of
understanding and management and that
big gap has been in groundwater so
people have been drawing down
groundwater basis because there's no
regulations there to manage it that
basic parallels New York in this sense
of in New York it's sort of been free
rein in terms of non potable water use
in turn and I'll talk about this in a
few minutes and toll only about three
years ago there were basically no
restrictions and most of you newark not
on the Susquehanna River Basin Delaware
River Basin but everywhere else if you
were non potable water user so a golf
course a farmer you basically could take
as much water you wanted never had to
report it and never had to tell anyone
so to some degree New York is sort of in
the place where the West has been with
groundwater is we really don't know very
much right so this is sort of the
motivated the two questions of this work
is can we shift agriculture back east if
we do that and we do we need water to do
that have we basically been using more
water for agriculture than we think in
the East and in New York and what do we
actually know about how much water users
been so those are those are sort of the
overriding questions okay so basically
four things will look at sort of four
different parts of the talk first one is
more antidotal but is there less water
than we think in New York and we'll do a
little case study on fall creek second
one is how much do we actually know
about agricultural water to man in New
York third is what sources of water
could agriculture make use of right
we're very different than the west where
they have snowpack they have large
reservoirs
been planning for irrigation basically
since the beginning of sadly not West
and then the fourth one is can we
actually demonstrate a benefit of
irrigation okay so place to start is
just thinking about sort of a case study
of what do we know about water use in
New York so we're going to look at fall
creek one reason it's nearby another
reason it's a good size right it's the
watershed at least above the gauge is
about 125 square miles so big enough to
actually have some water to do something
with but small enough to get a grasp on
so this is our map so we're right here
well yeah we literally are right here
right the gauge so one nice thing about
this watershed is it's actually gauged
most gauges in New York are either on
new york city water supply watersheds or
big rivers so this is actually a
relatively small watershed that's gauged
and then it has some interesting things
going on in terms of water use so
there's the Cornell water filtration
plant most people know Cornell has their
own water filtration plant we do then
there's several places where they pull
water out for irrigation all related to
Cornell so in varna they have some
irrigation sometimes and then there's
the Homer Thompson vegetable farm out in
freeville and then the other thing
that's interesting too is there's
discharge of water from dryden freeville
wastewater treatment plant so that's
actually inflow to the system and for
the most part that water we could kind
of consider it considered an out of base
and transfer and this sense that is
basically groundwater from homeowner
wells or from deeper groundwater it
might be in the the basin but it's
basically deep groundwater it's not
surface water okay so then we can space
you say can we do sort of some water
accounting for what we have available so
as I said it's really only been the last
few years that anyone's really bothered
to pay too much attention to what's
what's available so they see Cornell as
far as I know has really only done a
made an attempt to sort of compile the
records for the last four years so going
back to about twenty eleven luckily
though we've had some really dry years
in there so 2011-2012 base the approach
the his
torical lows in this summer so the
historical low is determined by going
back the USGS gauge goes back to
nineteen twenty five so basically
picking off the the monthly minimum all
the way back to nineteen twenty five so
2011-2012 come pretty close to those
monthly minimums right so we can get a
good sense of demand when you're
actually at your minimum in terms of
moisture availability okay so let's look
at some of the demands so Cornell AG
withdrawal is basically for irrigation
we can see sort of what we might expect
but often this data isn't available is
that when it's drier in 2011-2012 you
use more water and you use about four
times more water the thing to look at
here and will kind of put this all
together in a minute so everything is in
MGD anyone know what MGD is some people
probably not a lot of you so it's in
million gallons per day so that's in
water supply that's a pretty typical
measure is to use million gallons per
day okay okay so that's around 0.1
million gallons per day in terms of
maximum irrigation to man this is
monthly average this is the Cornell
filtration plant so they use quite a bit
more they use between one and a half and
two million gallons per day of water and
that's pretty consistent as we've been
doing this we've been learning some
interesting things about who uses water
and how they use it so the golf course
actually uses filtered water from the
water filtration plant whereas most
other places while irrigation on campus
just uses unfiltered water but we are
sort of surprised to find out okay so
putting these numbers together so the
one thing to realize is the withdrawals
and the gains to the system are all
upstream of the gauge so the gauge is
basically not telling you what's
available before you take anything out
it's basically telling you what's
available after you take things out so
it sort of is a good it's a relatively
good indication of the lowest available
Flo so if we basically look at the
filtration plant subtracting off Cornell
irrigation subtracting water and then
dried in freeville adding some water and
comparing that to 1964
this is the 1964 minimum assuming the
gains and losses are the same as they
are now we're not quite sure if they are
this would be September 1964 including
these current gains and losses so we'd
bassy it seems like if we look at
historical minimums drought of record we
would always have some amount of flow in
Fall Creek but 2.7 million gallons per
day isn't much flow does anyone know
probably what it's flowing at right now
Fall Creek want to put a number out
there I like to do this with my classes
I'd like to ask people make some guesses
it's probably about I didn't look at the
gauge it's probably around somewhere
around 100 mg d right now and in the
summer when you go out there and you
think it's pretty dry it's probably
around 20 mg d so if you say to MGT we
still have water that's not a lot of
water that's like that's basically a
trickle of water so main point is right
if we look at this we do still have some
water but not a lot right so we can base
E say within the historical record
drawing some water out of the system
we're basically getting to a point where
if you take much more water the system
you have nothing left right and people
haven't really as far we've talked to
Chris board lemay who runs the
wastewater treatment plant it's
interesting they have a number for what
their maximum withdrawal can be but it's
actually based on their plant capacity
it's not based on hydrology right so no
one is really out there looking to say
are there minimums that we have to meet
the other thing too is that these are
all based on monthly averages right so
we know within a month there's going to
be a variability but then within a day
there's variability so if you go and
look at the USGS gauge record and this
is this is instantaneous flow it's every
15 minutes you see this cycling like
this and we've actually been trying to
figure this out for a while what this is
because it's only shows up in the last
few years and what we realized is
Cornell change the way they operate
their plant so now they turn it off at
night for a few hours but what this does
is if your daily demand is to MGD but
you turn it off for half the time that
means your your demand when it's on is
for mg right so and if the if say if the
irrigation works the same way if they
only turn on certain times the date
off certain times a day your monthly
mean you might be meeting what you have
available but you could certainly be at
a point during the day we're actually
dry things out right where your
instantaneous demands exceed what you
have so it seems pretty reasonable just
based on this sort of this case study
that they're definitely can be places
one of them being fall creek in the
state where if people aren't really
looking at how we're withdrawing water
that we could potentially run out of
water one thing to note to this and as
we go on a little farther is the way
this operates is it's what we would call
run of the river system right so out
west your places like that ideally what
you have it's not run of the river you
have a reservoir some storage to draw on
but here we're basically just taking
whatever waters in the system is what
we're taking out as we talk about other
potential sources in New York State for
irrigation and water demand what we want
to look for is places where you it's not
run on the river where you actually have
storage if you think about New York
though we don't necessarily have a lot
of storage we have some we have the
Great Lakes we have the finger lakes but
they're not necessarily at an ideal
point to make use of them but we'll see
a little later on where we might
actually have a source that people don't
always think about okay so kind of part
two of this is to ask the question
besides just this case study what else
do we know about irrigation New York
State right are there any numbers out
there so there's basically two entities
that sort of make an attempt to put some
numbers together there's USDA so they
have their agricultural census every
five years and they ask some questions
about irrigation they basically asked
about irrigated acreage and then there's
USGS US Geological Survey that also
every five years comes out with
estimates of water use on a county basis
so these numbers official government
publications they're out there it's by
county it seems like it might be
reasonable to trust it so let's look at
some of these so I think that might be a
little small but you can probably kind
of see it from the back depending how
young you are or old you are so first
three columns USDA nass on national AG
statistical service data so that's
irrigated acres and then the last column
is USGS demand in terms of MGD right so
comparing kind of apples and oranges
one is acres one is actual demand just
some interesting stew interesting things
to pick out so Genesee County and I'll
show a map in a second well I'll
actually go do it right now so if you
don't know your your new york state
geography and you're wondering where
these places are so basically places
with most irrigation basie from gas or
liens genesee in wyoming counties those
are sort of the three highest ones
stacked up right there and then wayne
county and niagara county probably
sources or what their earring is a
little different Wayne and I are County
probably predominantly orchards
well-known right that's where most the
apple production is in the state and
then Orleans Genesee in Wyoming or liens
and genesee probably more vegetable
production Wyoming I actually don't
quite know I think it's mostly crops but
that's sort of part of the gap I don't
don't quite know what that is okay so
then our other source is thinking about
USGS demand how consistent is this the
interesting thing about the USGS demand
is it doesn't exactly correlate to the
acreage all right the highest one for
USGS demand does correspond to genesee
county but you have other counties with
relatively low acreage that still have
relatively high USGS demand numbers if
we go do just some back-of-the-envelope
calculations so I basically just took
MGD converted to cubic meters per year
something a little easier to think about
maybe and then kind of look at a few
possible irrigation rates so basically
centimeters per year and look at how
many acres irrigated would one done GD
give you so now we can kind of do a
comparison between acres and MGD so
irrigation rate it seems like 10
centimeters per year is probably the
high end in New York State it would be
hard to believe you have a year that's
much drier you need more than 10
centimeter year during growth growing
season so that would say 10 centimeter
per year irrigation rate could you could
irrigate almost 3,500 acres with one MGD
right so that would in Genesee County if
the numbers are right from USGS 55 MGD
at 10 centimeters per year would give
you 17,000 acres what NASA is reporting
to 6,000 acres seems like a pretty big
inconsistency right and that's even
going
true especially when you look at some of
these smaller counties with less acreage
like Erie County 3.36 MGD 390 acres
there's a pretty big inconsistency there
so clearly something's missing that we
don't know not surprising though usgs
says this for every county in the
country and if you look at the report
there's about five people on the report
so however they do this it's some way
where they really crank through it ok
but this basically raises more questions
than it answers right it basically says
doesn't tell you anything about how
often his irrigation occurring we trust
and ask data which i think is pretty
reliable it basically just tells us the
irrigated it tells us nothing about
actual demand it doesn't tell us how
much water is being used it doesn't tell
us where the water is coming from and
then there's this inconsistency point it
out ok so as I've sort of alluded to
there's more data becoming available and
if they see is coming from the New York
or the the Great Lakes compact which was
passed or at least discussed and agreed
to be passed back in two thousand eight
and a bassy agreement between states and
provinces in Canada about how to manage
their water and New York State as part
of that said they would actually start
to try to attract water usage non
potable water usage so in 2011 people
who used over a hundred thousand gallons
per day of non potable water use had to
basically start telling the state that
they were using the water it's basically
voluntary in the sense that the state
doesn't know if you don't report so but
what it does is it starts to give us a
data source ok so what this is is this
is for the most part people reporting to
dec who's collecting that data and this
is we we gon steelies the the address
associated with the user which it might
not literally be where it's taken from
but we're doing the best we can and then
this is overlaid over a crop map of
different types of crops in New York
State right so the yellow is corn the
darker green is soybean the pink is
alfalfa and you can kind of see the
darker red is usually some cases it's
apples in some cases it's dry beans and
things like that but it starts to give
you a pretty good sense of sort of some
distribution of thing
in New York State the other thing we
have added in here is I'll start to talk
about this in a minute is the Barge
Canal Authority also provides water to
people and if you take water from the
barge canal you have to get a permit so
we also have the blue dots are people
with a barge canal permit to draw water
okay so if you put this out there this
is sort of our best picture to date in
terms of sort of site-specific users of
irrigation water in New York State right
and if basie matches up with what we
knew from the nast data in terms of
people are center in orleans county
Genesee County and there's actually a
few more off the bottom let's see let's
go this way which get cut off their down
in wyoming county and for the most part
the dots lie in areas with agriculture
which is good so it seems like it's
consistent with what we're seeing so at
this point no we still don't really have
any idea of demand what how much water
they're using or where they're taking
water from one thing we do kind of know
is with the Dec data Elise it does have
it does give information about who the
user is so we can get some sense
actually there is a little bit of
withdrawal date i forgot what DC data
there is so we have some sense of demand
and then we have some sense of what
they're producing and for the most part
as i guess we might expect its fruit and
apples and vegetables so things that
would order cultural products that would
generally be more sensitive to water
demand okay so some examples up there
okay so one thing you might notice and I
sort of highlight here is we have a
large concentration along the barge
canal right anybody from New York State
have most people walked along the barge
canal just to get a sense a few people
okay a lot of people have it right so a
regional URI canal 1825 basically went
from just outside of Albany over to
Buffalo at the time upstate New York was
mostly forest land and it effectively
opened up the western frontier at the
time right just about every city in New
York State in upstate New York is AC on
on a river or on the Erie Canal what was
the Erie Canal and about
nineteen oh five or so the Erie Canal
was 80 years old they decided to update
it so they built the barge canal in some
places it stayed along the same path but
in other places like in city of
Rochester one around the outside of the
city of Rochester but she basically have
this almost 200 year old you know kind
of major engineering feat sitting out
there interestingly enough so I'll talk
more about in a minute I think it they
have a budget of over 100 million
dollars a year I think their revenue is
about a hundred thousand dollars per
year so if you ever wondered why your
taxes are so high or especially why it
costs so much to drive in the three way
you can partially think that your ear
canal so um okay but this is where the
Erie Canal goes on that western side of
the state it's basie totally flat and it
drains out of Lake Erie and then here's
our liens County that it cuts across and
then it eventually hits the Genesee
River over by Rochester so basically the
reason all that irrigation is there is
because they're taking advantage of the
barge canal a polling model of the barge
canal and it's basically it was so two
things I guess so the original Erie
Canal was actually intentionally built
up higher to avoid flooding when they
built the barge canal they built it
lower so it actually intersects the
Genesee River now which is a good thing
because it basically means what this is
it's basically a direct conduit from
Lake Erie across the state and it also
can potentially pull water from the
Genesee River so if you start to talk
about Israel way is there actually
infrastructure in new york state where
we can draw upon stored water the barge
canal is in because if basic connected
to the Genesee River and Lake Erie and I
don't think most people really look at
it that way but that's really what it is
so part of this project is basically
thinking about can we other ways to sort
of optimize the use of that
infrastructure
here's a nice view of things 1905
probably looks more quaint then than it
does now but I don't I don't think it
looks that bad now either this is Medina
so this is engineering report from 1905
which is interesting so basically when
they modify the Barge Canal from the
Erie Canal they intentionally recognize
so you know when you open the locks in
the canal you basically lose water so
you have to have a conta you have to
have a lot of water coming in so what
they realized was so they intentionally
made sure they had a large source of
water and heroes Erie Canal or the lake
erie and they basically put a number on
this so they say that it has a capacity
provide at least 1200 37 cubic feet per
second of water in this portion that
canal that's a lot of water in terms of
MGD that's about equivalent to about a
thousand MGD so there's a potential to
carry to convey a lot of to supply a lot
of water there another question you
might ask is raised so if it's not the
barge canal other other sources of water
in the state there are some aquifers a
lot of those correspond to two glacial
valley bottom aquifers for the most part
they're not extensively taps there are
some out there something else to
consider where we might go there but not
necessarily but just something else to
put out there okay so despite the fact
we know there's irrigation in the
northeast and in New York I think the
the other question that's out there is
is it scientifically is it defensible is
it necessarily is it necessary right we
know people are doing it so it seems
like it must have some value but is
there other other evidence out there of
what the value actually is so and I'll
just so surprisingly there's really not
that much information right i mean
there's a lot of farmers that kind of
say i think we need to do this and
they're doing it but at the same time if
you start to look for actual scientific
studies that show the need for it
there's not that there's really not many
out there at all so the one thing that
complicates things i think is most kind
of agronomy people know and especially
in the northeast as you have lots of
different factors controlling yield
right so i kind of at the top here i
just pick corn just because it was a
nice image i could find it easily
right but at the top I sort of have
different factors that can affect yield
so clearly in the Northeast early-season
wetness is a big one how soon can we
actually give the field and plant things
once things actually start growing is it
actually warm enough for the crop so do
we accumulate enough growing degree days
one things are growing do we have rain
we don't want so do we Flutterfield do
you think are things too wet and then
finally once once things are actually
getting mature and there's actually
quite a bit of water demand do we still
have enough water right and this is
really the fourth one is the one we're
really asking that's the one we're
trying to control with irrigation so the
difficulty in trying to understand is
how much of our yield is dependent on on
moisture availability is also trying to
to identify these other controls on your
yields right so you basically have a
bunch of factors a lot of them not
related to a moisture availability or at
least moisture available deficit that
you need to kind of eliminate to see if
how important that other factor is okay
so this is just showing kind of peak
demand for corn it's about 80 60 to 80
days in so by july august right that's
when we were most interested in having
water okay so some interesting studies
from people in canada actually so i
guess a group cowan and all they're
looking at horticultural crops so they
were doing two things they were looking
at temperature and they're looking at
mean seasonal temperature and then they
were looking at just days over 30 so
just sort of short sporadic changes so
they saw for a few things cabbage
cauliflower some significance just in
days over 30 degrees and then they
actually saw some significance with days
with rain not with growing season
precipitation but basie sort periods
without enough rain so a little bit of
evidence they're all your sources of
evidence out there that irrigation might
actually matter and sort of potentially
be useful in the Northeast so crop
insurance data which is out there as we
can see so this was for apples blue 14
kind of this is indemnities for crop
insurance certainly for apples freezing
is a much bigger deal than X
Moisture well actually excess
moisturizing the show up here right so
we do know that your get apples but it
appears and that might be the reason it
doesn't show up is because of the
irrigate of its already irrigated so
people don't need to don't include it in
terms of crop loss corn irrigation does
show up so most years at least lately
we've had too much water but 2012 is a
dry year it did show up as people
claiming crop insurance for lack of
water okay and then we've also been
doing some of our own analysis using
NASA data so National Attic sophistical
service data using county-level data and
what we just been doing is just starting
with relatively simple things so just
trying to predict annual yield and using
growing degree days i'm using june
precipitation and july precipitation
basically for sufficient water and then
use aim a precipitation for being too
wet early in the season so this is for
Livingston County this is down near kind
of Danville kind of dansville in the
kind of the center of the state and you
can see here not a great model but the
main thing I kind of look at is do we
get the quadrants right in terms of
observed versus predicted and the other
thing to note is that here importantly
if you if you just try to model just
using GDD and early season wetness alone
it's not significant so only when you
put in precipitation kind of summer July
June precipitation is it significant so
again some more evidence suggesting yet
yes precipitation their moisture during
the growing season important things get
complicated though so this is another
County this is Genesee County and in
this one we actually find the model the
best model is actually just includes GDD
and just includes may early season
moisture not summertime precipitation so
we're not quite sure right this is where
they're in the process of kind of
deciphering if you move around County to
County why do you things change one
thing there is a little bit of
irrigation in the county two percent but
probably not enough to make a difference
in terms of changing these relationships
here possibility of soils they might
have deeper soils
so even if you have less rain you have
more moisture availability over time but
we don't quite know so we're basically
trying to kind of decipher these
relationships and kind of get a better
sense of what's going on to make the
case that irrigation is actually
potentially useful alright and then this
is only for corn for vegetable crops and
things like that it might be a different
story okay so kind of the final part of
this is when we consider this and part
of this project was sort of considering
historically what's happened but then
also part of this is basically looking
at potential climate adaptation with the
assumption that thing's likely and will
change in the future so without at this
point we haven't done our own work but
looking at what other people have done
there is a paper by mcdonald and
Griffiths about two years back and they
for the entire United States looked at
moisture deficit using climate models
and then they basically on changes in
moisture deficit they used historical
relationships the irrigation given
moisture deficit and projected how
things might change so for New York
State they said there might be an
increase of up to 25,000 hectares and
irrigated acreage or Hector's and
irrigated land so they recognize
something kind of a well-known study
Anderson and all from about five years
ago looking at a climate assessment in
the Northeast they also use climate
models looking at changes this is in
soil moisture seasonal summer more soil
moisture and they saw decline in summer
soil moisture although not it's a
climate model so you know you can't put
that much if any trust in it but it
seems like they did see a decline of
about one centimeter so not a huge
amount so it seems reasonable to think
that there in the future there be some
additional moisture deficit and that my
kind of that might be equally important
to not only look and historically has
there been a need for irrigation but
basically changing sort of the equation
of can you justify it more in the future
so as you can kind of tell project is
based on going we've been doing this for
about six months and we basically are
going to do it for another year but I
think we can make a few conclusions
already and
kind of and then think about where we're
going to go so first thing is basically
given the reliance on run-of-the-river
supplies in New York State for the most
part it doesn't seem it does seem like
there is potential for conflict between
users I dunno like safer fall creek I
belong to a CSA which is ethical
organics they recently started farming
right next to the top Homer Thompson
vegetable farm and they have a plan to
irrigate so there's lots of small users
out there who might be using water that
don't necessarily fall under the 100,000
gallon per day thresholds report right
so for now there was people kind of
remain invisible but if there's enough
of them they might matter let's see the
remaining consistencies and what we do
know right in terms of NASA and USGS
it's basically no consistency there's
little consistency between that data
that's being put out there so clearly
clearly gaps and reporting despite not
really being intentional the barge canal
seems to be a really interesting
interesting piece of infrastructure it's
currently being used to some degree
evident by the number of people
clustered around it but I think there's
interesting question to ask of is really
you put more people around it and one
thing I don't really get into because I
don't have the information yet is right
there's an expense with the irrigation
and the irrigate you basically have to
say is the economical benefit from what
you can get an increased revenue does it
equate what you have to put it in terms
of capital right the barge canal is
potentially interesting because
everything is nice and flat it's already
right there it might be a pretty cheap
source of irrigation New York so it
might might be a pretty economical way
to irrigate nearby based on sort of some
analysis of what data is out there dry
periods do cause measurable declines and
yield despite other factors that cause
measurable declines so it's definitely
we can see it it's just a matter of
better eking out you know what is that
as a total percentage of loss really and
that's sort of the economic part and
then as I said at the end climate change
will probably make things more
economically feasible it seems pretty
likely things are going to become drier
in the future how much remains to be
seen so kind of remaining parts of our
project are basically to do an intensive
survey in the next few months of farmers
to basically get
more focused information in terms of
what sources of water they're using how
much are they using and what kind of
irrigation equipment are they using and
also what are the irrigating and then to
also continue on with with doing more
crop yield modeling to get a better
sense but in the end I think it should
be sort of an interesting picture of
sort of this to a degree sort of
untouched consideration of non potable
water use in New York State and going on
in the future it kind of it might be
some sort of some potential for future
investment in irrigation New York if you
can kind of make the case that there's a
place to boost production without
basically having too many competing
users for the water all in there and I'm
happy to take questions this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell edu